dans les eaux au large de la côte est des États-Unis.
Lors de cette accalmie, les chercheurs ont noté
que les baleines franches en danger dans cette région
avaient moins de marqueurs chimiques de stress dans leur échantillon de fèces.
Comme un chercheur à qui j'ai parlé aime le dire :
« Nous étions stressés, mais pas les baleines. »
Vous devez vous rappeler,
l'évolution a fait de nous une espèce visuelle.
Nous comptons vraiment sur nos yeux.
Mais la vie marine dépend du bruit
comme nous dépendons de la vue.
Pour eux, un océan bruyant
peut être aussi déroutant et même dangereux
qu'un brouillard dense l'est pour nous.
Et parfois, cela signifie simplement être un peu plus stressé,
ou peut-être que ça signifie passer moins de temps avec ses petits.
Peut-être que certaines espèces peuvent s'adapter.
Mais des chercheurs ont peur que pour les espèces en danger
déjà au bord du gouffre,
le bruit ne les y pousse au fond.
Donc prenons, par exemple, les orques résidentes du Sud
qui vivent dans les eaux de ma ville natale, Vancouver.
Il reste seulement 75, peut-être 76 animaux
de cette population.
Et elles affrontent de nombreux défis.
Il y a des polluants chimiques dans ces eaux,
et elles n'ont quasiment plus de saumons dont elles dépendent pour se nourrir.
Et puis, il y a le bruit.
Quand des chercheurs ont comparé ces orques à d'autres,
ils ont découvert qu'elles passent entre 18 et 25% moins de temps
à se nourrir en présence de bruits de bateaux.
Et c'est beaucoup pour une espèce qui a déjà du mal
à trouver assez de nourriture pour survivre.
La bonne nouvelle, comme l'ont dit tous les chercheurs à qui j'ai parlé,
c'est qu'il y a des solutions assez simples au bruit dans l'océan.
À l'inverse des problèmes vicieux du changement climatique
et de l'acidification des océans,
vous pouvez juste baisser le bouton du son des océans
et en voir les effets presque immédiats.
Ainsi, par exemple, en 2017,
l'administration portuaire Vancouver-Fraser
s'est mise à demander aux navires de simplement ralentir
lorsqu'ils traversent le détroit de Haro,
où les orques résidentes du Sud se nourrissent à la fin de l'été.
Un navire plus lent est un navire plus silencieux.
Et comme c'est le Canada, il suffit de demander,
cela peut être volontaire.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Lors du test de 2017, la plupart des navires ont obtempéré,
ajoutant une demi-heure à leur temps de trajet,
et réduisant ainsi le bruit d'environ 1,2 décibels
soit 24 % d'intensité du bruit.
Cette année, il a été décidé d'allonger la durée
et la zone sur laquelle les navires doivent ralentir.
Espérons que cela aura un impact positif sur les orques.
En 2017, l'administration portuaire Vancouver-Fraser
a aussi introduit des réductions sur les droits d'amarrage
pour les navires physiquement conçus pour être plus silencieux.
Bizarrement, beaucoup du bruit d'un navire comme celui-ci
provient de l'éclatement de petites bulles à l'arrière de son hélice.
On peut concevoir simplement un navire pour qu'il en fasse moins
et soit plus silencieux.
L'Organisation maritime internationale a publié une énorme liste de moyens
pour rendre les bateaux plus silencieux.
Et ils se sont aussi fixé comme objectif
de réduire les émissions de CO2 du trafic maritime mondial
de 50 % d'ici 2050.
Et la grande nouvelle c'est que les deux objectifs vont de pair.
Globalement, un navire consommant moins est un navire plus silencieux.
On a aussi inventé des méthodes plus silencieuses
de planter les poteaux géants
nécessaires aux éoliennes géantes, comme celles-ci,
et des méthodes plus douces pour faire des relevés sismiques.
Il y a des avantages à utiliser des technologies plus silencieuses.
L'Union européenne, par exemple,
dispose d'une directive pour les milieux marins sains en 2020.
Et l'une des façons dont elle définit un milieu marin sain,
c'est la quantité de bruit qui circule dans ces eaux.
Mais dans l'ensemble, la plupart des eaux restent complètement non réglementées
en ce qui concerne le bruit des océans.
À nouveau, beaucoup de scientifiques à qui j'ai parlé
disent qu'il y a une vraie dynamique politique
pour attirer l'attention sur ce sujet et peut-être y faire quelque chose.
Nous en savons déjà assez
pour dire que des mers plus silencieuses sont plus saines.
Les scientifiques s'efforcent de trouver des solutions détaillées.
À quel point faut-il être silencieux ?
Et où sont les meilleurs endroits pour faire le silence ou le préserver ?
Et comment pouvons-nous faire taire notre bruit ?
Je n'essaie pas de vous dire
que le bruit est le plus grand problème écologique de la Terre
ou même de l'océan.
Mais le fait est que l'humanité a beaucoup d'effets
sur notre système environnemental.
Et ces effets n'agissent pas seuls.
Ils agissent ensemble, et ils se multiplient.
Donc même ceux qui ne sont pas si évidents,
nous devons vraiment y prêter attention.
Je vous parlerai d'une dernière expérience,
juste parce qu'elle si belle.
Donc Rob Williams,
l'un des chercheurs qui travaille sur les orques résidentes du Sud,
travaille aussi un peu à Bali.
Là-bas, ils célèbrent une tradition hindoue
appelée Nyepi, ou journée de silence.
Et ce jour, apparemment, est très strictement respecté.
Aucun avion ne décolle de l'aéroport,
aucun bateau ne va pêcher,
les touristes sont gentiment conduits
hors des plages vers leurs chambres d'hôtels.
Et Rob Williams a mis quelques hydrophones dans l'eau
pour observer les effets
et ce fut spectaculaire.
Le niveau sonore a chuté de six à neuf décibels,
environ le même que dans les eaux après le 11 septembre.
Pour un « prospecteur acoustique » tel que Rob Williams,
comme il se nomme lui-même,
ce silence est d'or.
Lui et d'autres chercheurs peuvent retourner à cet endroit
et voir ce que les poissons décident de faire
de tout ce silence en plus.
(Bouillonnement doux)
J'aime à penser qu'ils ont leurs propres vacances,
qu'ils festoient et trouvent des compagnons.
Célébrant leur propre coin de calme
dans un monde ailleurs plus bruyant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)